it's time for drew's news your daily pop
of those good news muscle
remember like shana na bowser
thank you
thank you
and with me is my trusty co-pilot rossi
ross muscles
hi everybody hi hi
hi gorge well first up rossy we have got
some huge box office news it looks like
spiderman no way home is about to become
the highest grossing movie of all time
wow you think about that
there are 20 million away from
surpassing avatar which made 760 million
at the box office and buzzfeed reports
that tom holland oh i love him so much
got the news live while doing an
interview for his new movie uncharted i
just love tom holland so much i recently
posted this picture because i actually
met him many years ago
for a general meeting for a film i was
directing and he was the loveliest i am
the biggest tom holland zendaya
freakazoid i just root for these people
so much they're both so yes talented and
wonderful and good human most popular
movie in the history of ever that is
amazing you know back in the day et held
a world record of highest grossing film
do you remember when you heard that news
i do because it was very interesting
because it et beat out star wars and
george lucas and steven spielberg were
besties and then steven spielberg beat
out himself
for e.t with jurassic park oh right yeah
and then it went on to you know maybe
titanic and certainly avatar but um
yeah it's a it's a monumental feat and
uh it just goes to show how likable and
wonderful and talented these people are
next step rosie all right well next up
whether you work at home or you're back
at the office apparently what your desks
look like what it looks like on your
desk it says a lot about you metro asked
a psychiatrist to break it down and
here's what they said there are there
are four types of desks and drew i'm
wondering
which one you are because if you just
notice the the the news desk right here
you'll see her side and uh and my side
are a little different right this is
what does it say
well
let's see what uh what the different
deaths say about people like for example
if i'm tidy and minimalist like this uh
it says that i am dependable disciplined
conscientious and cautious oh okay
thanks for noticing uh-huh and good for
you rossie yeah i am kind of proud of
that let's see what it says if you are
messy and chaotic if that's what your
desk looks like it says that you're an
extrovert you're friendly you're super
creative
it also says you may be less productive
because you can't find anything on your
desk are you relating to that at all no
i know how to get it done
i love that about you i'm like a full
professional plate spinner i've got a
million things up in the air although i
am the person no one wants to give the
passports to
so i i would take the dependable out of
uh my part um friendly i why friendly
that's so weird like
that makes me happy i love people yes
you do like i really do love people so
they're right about the friendly part
that makes me happy well scientists got
it right
yeah and
we're not going to clean up no i'm not
changing
[Music]